aquí ya en varias muchas personas
haciendo fila para poder entrar a la
sala de la corte corrección a la sala 32
es allí donde debe comenzar este proceso
del día de hoy un proceso que debe
comenzar dentro de una hora y media y
que normalmente va a ver a la sesión
pero al parecer podría aplazarse de al
menos una semana esto porque si vea así
verás que es el magistrado que al
parecer del que se al que nicolas
sarkozy habría querido pues corromper
pues tienen algunos problemas de salud
así que podría aplazarse esto a partir
por una semana este proceso que debe
comenzar hoy 23 de noviembre y debería
ir hasta el 10 de diciembre
aproximadamente
natalia todo este caso inició con
escuchas telefónicas que pusieron en
duda de los dineros de la campaña de la
presidencia de sarkozy cuál es la
supuesta procedencia de los fondos y que
otros casos se enfrenta el ex presidente
bueno pues en realidad 22 varias
investigaciones en cuanto a esta
procedencia de los fondos por una parte
como lo decían en esta pieza que ustedes
escucharon hace un momento sobre el yang
betancourt la heredera de l'oréal la
mujer que la que era más la mujer más
rica de francia que habría pues he dado
unos unos dineros también a esa a esa
campaña del 2007 y los otros vendrían de
moamar gadafi y sería un hombre que se
llama el día de alta que jim y que es un
hombre de negocios franco-libanés quien
habría entregado unas dos son maletas
repletas de dinero a club de guión quien
era en esa época pues el secretario
general del elíseo por ahora pues estos
son al menos tres procesos en contra de
nicolás sarkozy que continúan pues
avanzando uno de ellos el marzo de 2021
que ya deberá abrirse